foreign
comes from Lucy in Florida I'm a senior
in college and I have no student loan
debt currently I have enough
scholarships and grants to cover about
85 percent of my expenses which include
my tuition class materials and rent out
of pocket I pay for my food toiletries
and car expenses I work about 19 hours
at 14 dollars per hour a week at a
student position at my college which
covers the other 15 percent of my
expenses I'm seeing multiple scholarship
opportunities that would apply to my
senior year award letter should I apply
to them the reason I am hesitant is
because I feel comfortable with my
financial situation and I don't want to
take the funds from students who might
need it more than me even if I was able
to get a hundred percent of my college
expenses covered I would still keep my
student position because it's valuable
work experience towards my future career
in data analytics what should I do
whew that's an interesting question
um I love that you haven't taken out any
student loans I love that you can pay
for your tuition and it doesn't sound
like student loans are on the table so
if you feel comfortable continuing to do
what you're doing and pay for your
expenses and graduating debt free then I
mean by all means continue doing it the
fact that you're asking this question
makes me think that you feel a little
uneasy with taking the scholarships and
if you don't want to I mean that's fine
but also there's nothing ethically or
morally wrong
for in going for the scholarship so I
really don't think you can go wrong
either way yeah you're not doing
anything wrong by taking the scholarship
you're a very sweet kind person and
you're not harming someone else okay go
get the scholarship kiddo yeah go get it
put the money in the bank let it be your
uh insurance policy that you are able to
finish up school debt free
um you're a very content person which
also means you have a very high
probability of Building Wealth it's one
of the big ideas that we push all the
time is contentment and you're not a
greedy person you're not a person who
sets out to harm others you know or to
gain at someone else's expense and none
of that is occurring when you take this
scholarship none of it is occurring
there is bazillions of dollars of
scholarships that go unclaimed every
year and so you need to go get this
scholarship as many of them as you can
get and uh you've done nothing wrong by
doing that they're issuing the
scholarship not based on whether or not
you need it they're based they're basing
it based on the information you give
them in the application right yeah
you're not harming anyone else from
pursuing these great opportunities
absolutely